bonjour c'est un gel pour brut moi je
pars du principe que je ne vais pas
relire les interviews parce que sinon
j'en viendrais malades bas à une
question
alors comme à beaucoup posé qu'on me
pose beaucoup moins depuis la sortie du
clip de balances ton quoi ces études
féministes parce que il ya deux choses
dans cette derrière cette question il ya
une première chose de si on pose la
question c'est forcément être féministe
c'est comme une sorte de statement qu'il
faudrait vraiment assumé alors que pour
moi ça coule de source et la seconde
chose c'est tu féministes comme si du
coup le fait de vouloir parler
d'indépendance d'égalité faisait qu' il
fallait mettre une étiquette là dessus
si tu t'étais le fait d'être féministe
et donc c'est comme si c'est un peu
péjoratif moi je le vois comme ça et je
me souviens qu'il ya encore un an et
demi quand j'étais en train d'écrire
balance tout quoi quand on posait cette
question parce que j'avais porté un
t-shirt où on parlait du pas de faire
cas du fait que les femmes avaient
besoin de plus de sommeil que les hommes
parce qu'il fallait se battre ou de
partir le patriarcat que c'était
épuisant et j'avais plus de porter ce
tee shirt comme ça peu fier on a fait
cette photo avec charlotte abramoff et
du coup cette question est revenue assez
vite et comme à ce moment là moi même
j'avais j'avais peur de prononcer sur le
féminisme
parce que je me rendais bien compte que
c'était que c'était un sujet assez
sensible et bien je patauge et un peu je
savais pas trop comment se positionner
et puis bah en grandissant on me
renseignant on essaie d'en apprendre
chaque fois de plus en plus je me suis
rendu compte qu'ils avaient pas de honte
et qui avait pas de mal et qu en fait
être féministe sa voulais juste dire
vouloir l'égalité et qu'après il y avait
plein de choses qui découle est ça et
qu'il y avait plein de deux manières
d'être féministe et surtout il y avait
plein de choses que je ne connaissais
pas donc je suis toujours en train de
grands signes et là dessus parce qu'en
fait j'ai plein de choses à apprendre
mais je crois qu'il faut pas avoir peur
de parler de féminisme pas ce que ça
veut juste dire vouloir l'égalité en
fait ça par sa part dollars après plein
de féminisme il ya pas de féminisme
différent et il ya encore plein de
combat et a même des combats qui me
concerne pas directement mais que
j'essaie d'apprendre que j'essaie de
comprendre et que j'essaye moi même de
combattre même indirectement
est ce c'est le poilu parce que ce sont
des vrais poils parce que ça veut dire
que les gens vont pas regarder les clips
déjà donc ça me vexe un peu ce que
j'écris beaucoup d'ego et est ensuite
qu'est ce qu'on s'en branle en fait ce
fou que ça ça mais vrais poils ou pas
l'idée c'était justement dans cette
image où je suis d'abord et celle look
épiler et puis convient de poser des
poils dessus pour les personnes qui
n'ont pas fait l'effort de regarder nos
types
en fait l'idée c'était justement de
montrer qu'il y avait pas de règles
qu'en fait on fait absolument ce qu'on
veut de notre corps et donc il n'y a
aucune justification à avoir des fêtes
de s'épiler ou de passer pilé et ça
devrait même pas être un sujet en fait
sauf que ça en est un et donc où on a
joué avec ça on étudie dans cette image
qui comme une image assez forte pour le
clip la concurrence avec votre frère ça
se passe comment comme si le fait qu'on
soit phare et soeurs voulait forcément
dire qu'il y avait de la concurrence et
c'est une manière assez malsaine en fait
de nous lier là où justement on faire un
mois c'est carrément ce qui nous a
complètement connecté ces derniers
mais c'était de faire le même métier et
c'était qu'en plus de ça on avait chacun
notre place dans notre métier ce qui
n'est pas toujours simple et c'est
partir du principe qu'il ya une
concurrence alors qu'il n'a pas et ça
c'est chiant parce que parce que ça ça
fait exister quelque chose qui n'existe
pas en fait donc ça s'est compliqué et
puis en fait justement avec romain on a
toujours on a toujours l'habitude de
donner de la force et de et de se
supporter et de se soutenir
donc donc ça c'est moi ça me moi ça me
fait chier parce que ça voudrait dire
que qu'on pourrait pas être deux
artistes avoir chacun notre histoire et
qu'il faudrait forcément qu'elles soient
mises en compétition
ouais est ce que tu peux nous dire une
phrase avec des frites et l'accent belge
banon enfin je sais pas on ne fait pas
ça avec les marseillais où c'est bizarre
de demander ça et puis puis forcer une
blague c'est toujours un peu nul et
après j'avoue que moi je je me la
raconte à mort avec la belgique et on a
un côté a montré qu'on est fier d'être
belge et où je crois que c'est un peu
c'est un peu parce que parce que la
belgique qui est un petit pays qui n'a
pas toujours été aussi bien considérer
que depuis ces dernières années
on semblait beaucoup moqué nous mêmes
aussi on aime bien se moquer de nous
mêmes
mais du coup j'ai enfin moi en tout cas
j'ai toujours un petit pincement quand
on me demande de faire l'accent belge
parce que j'ai pas envie de me [ __ ] de
la gueule
mon propre pays et que je trouve ça un
peu bizarre c'est chouette de se moquer
des accents avec les amis entre nous que
moi en tant qu'artiste qui viennent
belgique je commence a moqué de l'accent
des belges je trouve qu'il ya un côté un
peu déplacée parce que parce que ça
devient condescendant en fait et moi
juste pas du tout envie d'être
condescendance et et puis même en voie
de les accents en général on se les
approprient et je lui dis un truc qui va
enfin chez plus d'un mais je connais pas
un seul français qui sache faire
l'accent belge a et ça c'est le fait
juste pas en fait si moi je le fais pas
y'a pas de raison que que les fonds
cette façon